what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation thank you so much for
being here we're gonna watch episode
four and five of the i am groot shorts
episode one through three are all in a
separate video they're compiled together
there our reaction for that uh really
enjoyed the first three
a lot this has been really surprisingly
enjoyable you know there's a part of me
i was wondering this could be a waste of
time they're so short but it's been
really really enjoyable yeah just the
right pitch yeah yeah so guys you can go
ahead and check that out uh if you only
want to see these two episode four and
five then sweet stick around leave a
like i mean a lot also subscribe and
click that notification bell we got
she-hulk coming out next week so you
know you want to if you're a model fan
you're gonna want to be with us koi will
be joining us also a full-length
reaction watch alongs where you sync up
with the time code or your own copy
meaning your disney plus account over at
our patreon page for super sexy rejects
thank you to the team at prepper for
helping us edit these down let's get
that to it
[Music]
little pac-man ghosts too
it's a ruckus
[Music]
chris pratt in the shower
don't drop that bars
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is the guardians of the galaxy
easter egg video
what are you doing man
[Music]
duct tape solves all
oh man wait are those the ships fuel
rods
ah wait how'd you get the walls wet and
on fire
is that
drax's soap drax was in the shower ah
dang how did you get hey hey don't give
me that look don't think you're getting
at us by being cute why are you handing
me this what is this more trash
better be a written apology you see this
oh
oh
oh this is very
nice the top of the fridge
i can't stay mad at you can i
get my tail here
i saved him
i almost tore the ship apart
i forgot that they said bradley cooper
was coming back yeah
for a second there i was like it's him
right
no i didn't i could hear bradley
cooper's voice
yeah especially when he does the more
like calm delivery
no
hopefully this photo returns in the
holiday special
they all got a little santa hat
20-minute season finale here we go stick
the landing final episode
better nail this
[Music]
yeah you could be on castaway
oh
hierarchy
[Music]
i am god
i am
[Laughter]
i am
[Music]
oh
jeez
[Applause]
[Music]
groot's going on galactus and he
[Music]
full offensive
a bug's life
[Music]
i gotta poop more leaves
i was gonna kill him
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you should have massacred those tiny
creatures
i thought i was going to drop it on them
too harsh yeah
and this is among vin diesel's finest
performances
you know i i feel like there's a way you
could make an i am groot like
movie like
like a pixar movie yeah you know like
you did it with wall-e yeah and where
those two characters
you eventually get to some characters
who say more like the way how it's been
here where like you occasionally bump
many characters who who like can
actually talk or you get more dialogue
but for the most part movie like wally
was so much more
just kind of silent film and just the
same repetitive words all through
visuals and body language and expression
and this was i was really engaged in all
five of these
and i was like you could make some type
of story that is like a solid 80 minutes
and i definitely tuned in for that
because this i am gorgeous groot is such
an adorable character so so endearing
and adorable and watching them learning
and getting these
just the mixtures of of exploring
lifestyle and i love the way they handle
like the perspectives here especially in
the final episode
of you know like he's small with the big
animals and the hierarchy of the chain
and taking taking him out that other
bird and then he's now the god amongst
them and the imposing figure i love the
way that it all looked and like yeah the
visuals are undoubtedly beautiful and
then you get the family theme with the
one with rocket there's
i don't know i was i'm pleasantly
surprised by how much i enjoyed these
it's not like
it doesn't feel important
in terms of the grander scheme of the
mcu whatsoever but if you put that to
the side this was uh like
more than a lot of times if you say
something just like really cute and
enjoyable kind of just sounds like
something you could like i'll skip it
yeah for kids whatever i'm not a kid
even though i make a lot of noise about
my inner child
yeah
i thought this was really really sweet
and endearing and and very touching so
yeah i i quite enjoyed it i would like
this is the kind of thing i would like
show to people
just that that watch is cute yeah i mean
it makes me really happy that they
took the time and resources to make
something like this because they don't
have to this doesn't seem like
you know the biggest money driver you
know business decision but i do
appreciate that like this had so much
care put into it because i absolutely
agree it's like you could make a movie
out of this in the way that you know
there is important dialogue in wally but
a lot of like the dialogue across these
episodes that shows up isn't
the most important part to you
understanding how everything works it is
still mostly visually driven mostly
driven on action and body language and
stuff like that and so i would i would
be really delighted and dazzled if they
grew their animation department further
out you know we have stuff like what if
and we're having you know x-men 97 and
spider-man uh you know freshman year
like all these different animated things
but this feels
different and because it's groot because
you're sort of in the live-action
feeling world like it feels like it
occupies kind of a special niche and
yeah like i would love to see more
either in this format or in a longer
format because it's interesting
storytelling and you can kind of feel
just the difference just the kind of
difference in consideration and
sensibility that goes into yeah a
largely
dialogue-less story you know something
that is just all about tones and actions
and and
thoughtfulness and quirkiness and and
whimsy
um so yeah like i love
expansions on the mcu that are like this
or any any universe really that are like
this where it's like this isn't the tone
and media i'm used to seeing here but
i'm very glad it is here
yeah or they can make a movie and just
minging it up
grew and then he's got like a bunch of
clone baby groots they just take all the
cutest things market testing loves and
they just jam packed the movie they come
up with the most like you wrote it in a
weekend
story but no if they did like a wall-e
type thing where they really considered
like if if you know the people who wrote
this i think it was the same writer
director for all these like if they
collabed with james gunn or something he
came up with like a full-on story and
really
this person wrote uh blue valentine
it shows yeah it shows boy
yeah if they if they were able to kind
of develop something longer form with
that you know wally feel to it i think
they also wrote a revolutionary road
definitely a revolutionary road
eyes wide shut
written by them yeah vanilla sky
uh so yeah if you can get some of those
themes in there too basically it's
romantic life
like an erotic thriller yeah yeah or a
hard-hitting you know a poignant
hardship look
at relationships yeah recruits people
maybe do one where like groot gets like
a a life-ending disease or something
like that oh i like that maybe we made
the very finale just to really hit it
home yeah to really make it really get
the feels going because you know if you
get people to cry that's a sign it's a
good film yeah yeah do angels in in the
multiverse or whatever yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh like angels in the city in it
yeah you know
in america angels in america with groot
yeah and then do angels in the outfield
i think that would be a very one-sided
game
you know he'd make his own bat
he would stretch his arms out
all right guys what do you think about
these i really enjoyed them not just
saying that like it was just really
enjoyable great
it was it was really pleasant yeah it's
nice to see something like just animated
that is you got to pay attention to it
yeah you got to drink in the details you
got to pay attention to the action
instead of just a bunch of noise and
dialogue like it's like you know it's
like animation stuff can feel so
bombastic and just so like
kids are into tick tock [ __ ]
they all start off kind of slow and then
they build over time and yeah like these
feel this is like the best ways
there was something that felt like
the word that comes to mind is serene
there's something there's very there's
serenity vibe to it you know um so yeah
i enjoyed that i was really blissful and
and delightful
uh
i don't know
this could have been so just okay or so
like uh this is for kids i get it but
it's not really for me like this this
was wonderful it's like this is for
everybody in in a great way and the
animation too you can't say it like the
just the details and the particles like
they they really look gorgeous and
tangible again it really makes you feel
like you're watching these animated
shorts but in the live action universe i
felt like they really cared to put
something
put these together i think that's always
another thing that really surprised me
i'm so surprised by how much character
doesn't feel like it doesn't feel like
yeah just throw it in there get your
money you have the kids watch it then
we'll merge them up we'll merge up group
some more uh which i'm sure they're
going to be doing 100
but
a real lego set for each short i am i'm
i am surprised by how much
how much more much more thoughtful this
was yeah yeah yeah it's not like deep
and hard-hitting in the fields or
something like that but it feels in a
different way yeah but yeah they have
enough interesting emotions and nuances
that it does catch you in some kind of
feel and that's that's
a great little yeah it doesn't always
have to be grim yeah to catch you in the
fields you know
or uh yeah try to go for something
melancholic or something yeah that was
great all right guys so leave your
thoughts down below what'd you think of
the iron groot series uh do you want to
see more of these short films
subscribe click that bell leave a like
let's send this with a patreon
kevin smart new to our patreon page
so you're getting a traditional shout
out yeah i'm doing the elvis point man
k stands for
kick it cool
cool with a k
e stands for even cooler with a k than
greg and john v stands for
vicariously cool
i stands for in it cool comma kevin
n stands for no one cooler than the kev
dude you are the coolest and you're
freaking smart you're smart you don't
get too many smart people out there
everyone's dumb but yes my smart how do
you like them apples yeah i like that
the town ben affleck dude
departed all right guys well thank you
kevin for being here hopefully you enjoy
the patreon
or you just pledge share support don't
care about anything we have to offer
over there either one's okay with us
see you buddy
[Music]